hello
everyone and welcome to today's live
broadcast
bio layer interferometry as a strategic
platform to validate covalent
proximity inducing small molecules with
synthetic tumor
immunotherapeutic applications i am
sabrina lamoos of
lab roots and i will be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by
sartorius for more information about our
sponsor
please visit their site at sartorius.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click the send button
if you are having trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking the
ask a question box located to the far
left of your screen i'd now like to
introduce our presenters
dr anthony rulo assistant professor
chemical immunology department of
pathology and molecular medicine
mcmaster immunology research center
department of chemistry and chemical
biology
mcmaster university and dr neil
schatz-salem
marketing applications manager at forte
bio
for a complete biography on our
presenters please visit the biography
tab
at the top of your screen dr saleem you
may now begin
your presentation
hello and welcome again to our webinar
today i will give you a short
introduction to octet biola
interferometry platforms
before i hand over to prophecy ruler who
will talk about his research
developing small molecule
immunotherapeutics
octet bilayer interferometry platforms
are commonly used in three main types of
applications
among others kinetic characterization
involves the measurement of binding on
rates
off rates and affinities between a range
of analytes
from small molecule peptides antibodies
to larger nanoparticles liposomes or
even
cells octa platforms are used in
quantitative applications as well
performing immunoassays for biologics
quantitations
where users can adopt a direct one-step
sandwich
or a multi-step assay format to achieve
sensitivities
from milligrams per ml to picograms per
ml
octet elisa's are rapid and efficient
where quantitation of a full 96 well
plate of iggs for example can be done in
two minutes with the hdx
octa platforms are also ideal as a
screening tool where
binding data can be used as part of a
hit selection campaign
a test for functional activity of
biomolecules
a screen of epitope binning or even rank
ordering for protein expression analysis
or binding affinities
co2 blight technology is the biosensor
where binding interactions take place
and are monitored
the biosensor consists of a fiber optic
attached to a polypropylene hub
with a specific chemistry available at
the end of the biosensor tip
that will enable you uh to capture a
specific ligand
uh immobilize a ligand a typical octet
experiment
would involve immobilizing one binding
partner to the biosensor
before the biosensor goes and it reads
for binding
of from a sample plate with test
analytes
let's take a look at how octet biolumi
interferometry measures
binding so the technology is based on
um biola interferometry where white
light
travels through a fiber optic cable and
goes through the highly reflective layer
that is available
at the end of the biosensor surface now
when there is
a binding interaction what happens is
the bio layer at the end of the
biosensor tip does
increase in thickness because you are
attaching small
attaching molecules uh as the binding
complex forms
now what happens is the light is
reflected back from this highly
reflective layer to the detector
and as the thickness increases you'll
see like the detector will see light
wavelengths traveling off of slightly
longer distances
that creates an interference pattern now
what happens is
this progressing bio layer
will enable calculation of the
association rates
as the signals does increase when
binding complex forms and these
measurements are done in real time so
next what happens is
the dissociation of the biomolecule from
the biosensor
now what happens is the dissipation of
the thickness
of the bilayer and that is also a
kinetic measure where it will give you
the dissociation rate constant and the
affinities
so these are the off-the-shelf biosensor
chemistries we have to offer
um to help immobilize one binding
partner to the biosensor
also note that we have biosensors
recommended for kinetic and quantitation
applications
so if you want to immobilize an antibody
based ligand for example
you could use uh fc capture chemistries
or protein agl-based biosensors
uh based on the species of and the
isotype of the antibody for immobilizing
recombinant proteins one could use
are capture biosensors his capture
biosensors anti-gst
or streptavidin based chemistries we
also have
offer biosensors that can immobilize
ligands based on traditional
amino and reactive chemistries or
hydrophobic based absorption
using aps biosensors we offer several
kits as well
that can be used for quantitative
contaminants such as
residual protein a and choho cell
proteins
and we have a kit for gly s acelic acid
glycan screening
lastly i would like to introduce uh
affordability range of bli label free
instruments
as you can see we have a we have to
offer a range of platforms to choose
from
based on your throughput and sensitivity
needs and also budget
in the top of the table we have the
benchtop single channel
blitz system that is a lowest throughput
system that is intended for large
molecular analysis
next we have our automated octet
platforms in
increasing throughput from top to bottom
the k2
the red 96e the red 384 and the hdx
are the most sensitive bli platforms
that can even characterize
and detect small molecule interactions
the blue qke
octet system is ideal for large molecule
kinetic characterization and
quantitation
the throughput of each system is
governed by the number of
channels in each instrument so we have
system that has two channels
8 16 and the hdx has 96 channel so
with the hdx one would be able to
collect
up to 96 simultaneous kinetic traces or
data points
so on the right we have some key
benefits to using an octa platform in
your research
that includes bringing you providing you
the ability to rapidly characterize and
develop binding interactions or assets
in real time optic does not use fluidics
to route samples to biosensors
so in octet workflows the biosensor is
the one that moves to a micro well plate
and a depend read measure
collects binding responses since the
liquid does not travel out of the plate
at any point there is no concerns of
clogging
and enables analysis of samples that are
in complex matrices
such as lysate serum and plasma that
lets you cut down on your sample
preparation
or protein purification types also the
samples are non-destructive
and can be really can be reused of the
plate if needed
so one other thing is octet platforms
are walk-in ready systems where no
instrument cleanup
before and after or a preparation step
is needed so you can run back-to-back
experiments
or get more experiments done in a day
with that
i would like to hand off hand over to
professor anthony rulo
our featured speaker today to talk about
his research
dr anthony
thank you very much nelson that was a
great introduction
so today i'll be speaking about uh one
of the major research
platforms in our group um where the
where validation using the
the octet biosensors has proved critical
in our ability to inform
compound validation design decisions and
so what i'm showing here is the
general concept of this research
platform in our group
where we develop these molecules that
are that are designed
to really modulate the proximity of
endogenous proteins immunological
proteins
that are already in our body with target
cells and in this particular application
those being cancer cells
and so we're showing here in this little
schematic
is the is the bifunctional tool with a
green sphere and a red
square you'll see this notation
throughout the presentation this denotes
two different binding selectivities
one for each protein you're trying to
bring together
and this particular application the by
functional molecule
brings antibodies that are already
present in the bloodstream
um two target cancer receptors shown
here by this brown
receptor that you could imagine being on
a cell surface okay
and the molecule the small molecule
increases the proximity between these
two biological components
when your immune system when certain
receptors on immune cells
that are also circulating throughout
your body see the antibody
localized to the surface of a target
cell that causes receptor clustering and
activation leading to immune function
and cytotoxicity against the target cell
which in the case of cancer cells
can eliminate the cancer cell which
which represents
a viable immunotherapeutic outcome
so just to provide a little bit of
context here this general idea of
of modulating proximity
is is not new in tumor immunotherapy and
so a lot of
a lot of very attractive
immunotherapeutic
hits and leads and and that are
currently in the clinic um
operate based on this principle and so
i'm just highlighting two really popular
examples of immunotherapeutics that
operate through this increase
in proximity shown here in this box
are therapeutic antibodies that are
engineered
to recognize tumor antigens that are
highly expressed on the surface of a
tumor shown here by these red receptors
so the antibody binds both to these
receptors that are highly expressed and
also have binding sites for immune cell
receptors
like natural killer cells for example
and so the engagement of both of these
proteins
increases the proximity of the immune
effector cell with the cancer cell
leading to
targeted cytotoxicity which this
particular mechanism is known as adcc
or antibody dependent cell mediated
cytotoxicity
another popular type of
immunotherapeutic
tumor immunotherapeutic engager as
they're known is our bi-specific t-cell
engages which i'm sure many of you are
familiar with again the same
principle where you have two different
protein binding domains with specificity
for a cancer cell surface antigen
as well as a immune cell in this case a
t
cell receptor and so by binding both you
bring the t
cell in close proximity to the cancer
cell and then
through subsequent cell signaling and
clustering events you get t
cell mediated killing of the cancer cell
these are really attractive cancer
therapeutics due to the potential for
very high targeted selectivity
and we got interested in this field from
the chemical biology perspective
because we we interpreted
and and noticed we're made aware of a of
a difficulty
and being able to actually maximize the
formation of the desired complex
so it's not trivial to develop a
therapeutic
that no not only has to bind one target
but actually has to bind to and only
when both are bound you get
the therapeutic response and so this
becomes almost a bio
biophysical uh physical problem um and
is
in the realm of of chemical biology and
it makes for a great biological question
to probe with chemical tools and so this
is how we got inspired to develop
technologies to really probe
these interactions and try and modulate
them using small molecules
so kind of let me build off some of the
more recent precedent in this work
are a class of such engager molecules
that go by
different names um one popular name is
antibody engager molecules or antibody
recruiting molecules known popularly as
arms
and shown in this specific example is a
small molecule
that contains a a serum antibody binding
domain so it finds antibodies already in
your blood
um one particular class are known as
anti-nitrophenol antibodies and so they
recognize this dinitrophenol hapten that
you can see here on the
bottom left of the slide and this arm or
antibody engager is also equipped
with a cancer antigen binding ligand
okay um and in this particular case
it binds to a tumor protein antigen
known as eupar or ural kinase
plasminogen activator receptor
which is highly overexpressed on a
number of metastatic cancer cells
and so the idea is that the small
molecule engager binds both to the
antibody
and the cancer antigen and in its
simplest reductionist form you can see
forms this immunologically active
ternary complex in the center
you where you have the bifunctional
molecule that has
that is bound to both the naturally
occurring antibody in your blood and the
cancer cell
okay and so in this way it engages both
proteins
um in this way it increases the
proximity between antibodies and cancer
cells
when you have a multivalent display of
these ternary complexes on the target
cancer cell
you then if you remember our opening
slide activate immune cell receptors
which carry out the actual cytotoxic
killing okay
and so we thought about this process
from a from a more physical chemical
biological
biological perspective and so what we
were considering were
questions such as you know how does the
concentration and valency of these
ternary complexes on the target cells
impact
the anti-tumor efficacy of these engager
molecules
okay and you can imagine that in
studying this particular arm system
a lot of the findings could be generally
translatable to
all types of of immunotherapeutic
engager
therapeutics which currently are largely
biologic so by specific proteins like we
saw in the case of the bite or by
specific t
cell engagement um another question we
became interested is how how would
how would tumor cell killing turnover by
immune cells be be affected
by these ternary complexes okay as well
as the therapeutics half-life itself
if it gets cleared from systemic
circulation too
quickly um on the time scale of these
immune activation cytotoxic killing
processes
um then that provides a real avenue
for for medicinal chemistry to try and
improve the pharmacokinetics so we were
really interested in a lot of these
kind of physical basic uh science
problems
in tumor immunotherapy using small
molecule engages
and on the next slide i'm just going to
get a little bit more into
antibody recruiting molecules and
engagers and and
simplify the binding interactions so you
can kind of um understand
what we're what we're really thinking
about how we're thinking about these
systems and
the kinds of biological questions we're
after so
you know you can imagine typical to any
any bifunctional molecule
you have to consider the process of in
vivo clearance of the bifunctional
molecule so in this
simplified equilibrium scenario we're
just showing antibody engagers
so remember this binds serum antibodies
as well as
proteins that are highly expressed on
the cancer surface
that are absent from normal tissue or
are more likely present at lower
densities on normal healthy tissue
so in any case you would have the
engager bind in any particular order to
the antibody with a certain affinity
as well as the protein shown here by
this brown receptor on the target cancer
cell surface
um it's difficult to control the order
of binding in this particular scenario
i'm in the absence of cooperativity
however the fact that this would be
administered
in vivo into the serum would likely
encounter ceremony body first before
encountering the localizing to the site
of a solid tumor or cancer cells and so
we're simplifying this this scheme under
a certain set of conditions where we
administer excess antibody engager to
make sure we saturate
all available antibody and assume that
the engager binds
antibody before a target protein you can
imagine how complex this equilibrium
scenario really is in
in true biology as well as considering
the antibody engager clearance
and how this clearance can potentially
drive dissociation
okay of the of the much needed ternary
complex
for efficacy when we form this ternary
complex we would have this
somewhat reversible process that engages
the immune cell receptor like a natural
killer cell which
then results in turnover in an
irreversible process leading to
cancer cell killing one of the one of
the key considerations
in these types of engager modes of
action
is the dose and so depending on the
binding affinity of the molecule
for the target protein in this
particular case let's say the antibody
you need to administer a large excess
potentially to saturate all available
antibodies
the problem becomes this auto inhibition
phenomenon where if you have
excess you'll actually your therapeutic
engage will actually auto inhibit its
own function
by forming these binary complexes shown
on the bottom labeled
um with this term auto inhibition and so
this
these equilibrium constraints are are
actually pretty unique from a
pharmacokinetic perspective with all by
functional therapeutics
um and we wanted to think a lot more
about
about how these types of equilibrium
processes
impact therapeutic efficacy okay so i'm
just kind of
laying down the groundwork for for why
our platform explores these covalent
immune recruiting molecules
okay so the take-home message on this
slide is really
you know it's very difficult to to study
and to maximize
these multi-component complexes needed
for immune function
um particularly in vivo when you can't
easily control
binding affinities and endogenous
concentrations of these target proteins
which very likely could be quite low
in the sub nanomolar range
and so really our kind of three major
research questions um
at this point are really the looking
more specifically now
in the case in the specific context of
antibody
engager molecules is this question of
endogenous antibody concentration and
binding affinity
we wanted to explore are these
sufficient for maximal
ternary or quaternary complex formation
and immune activation
just for simplicity we define ternary
complex as one
where the bifunctional molecule is
engaged with the cancer cell and the
antibody
and quaternary complex when you have the
added binding to immune cell receptors
that's needed that leads to
function anti-cancer function we're also
interested in exploring
how maximizing these these quaternary
complexes
in vivo basically leads to or modulates
the anti-tumor response as we know in
tumor immunotherapy
achieving a prolonged anti-tumor
response is critical
to prevent relapse okay which is a
common problem especially with solid
tumors
and we're also interested in looking at
how these ternary quaternary complex
complexes from the perspective of their
concentrations on the target cell
surface as well as their lifetime
disabilities
how does this modulate therapeutic
function
and so to to really get at these
questions and interrogate these
processes we came up with a with a
concept
drawing on on established chemical tools
in the in in the literature um
to basically be able to make certain
steps in this complex binding process
irreversible
okay and so what we do is we developed
by functional molecules that had this
additional ability
upon binding the target protein to
actually lock onto it and form a
proximity induced covalent linkage which
is a
which is a popular chemical tool
especially in proteomic profiling
and so we thought this would be really
interesting for a few reasons um if you
look at our
are what we're now calling a cir or
covalent immune recruiter
in the in context of antibodies this can
bind the antibody and the target tumor
protein
on the on the surface of the cells but
it does something else in this
particular example
this molecule which you can imagine in
viva would also be
rapidly cleared in vivo usually around
two hour half-lives for small molecules
in this molecular weight range around
one kilogram this molecule can bind an
antibody
and in this particular reaction i'll
show you the particular chemistry used
in this specific example the
the domain that binds to the endogenous
antibodies then ejected
but effectively you now have an antibody
that's permanently covalently attached
to
a tumor binding ligand shown by this red
square and unlike small molecules
antibodies
circulate for quite a long time in the
body so we thought this would be a
really interesting way
of exploring how the role of in vivo
clearance on the
tumor immunotherapeutic function okay by
specific proteins
like bites also are rapidly cleared in
vivo
um and so the idea is that you have this
accumulation of
antibodies now functionalized with tumor
binding molecules you could think of it
as being
covalently recruited now to a target
tumor protein so
it's now no longer dependent on binding
of a bifunctional molecule to the
antibody because now the antibody is
permanently programmed if you will with
tumor binding capabilities
so this also probes the importance of
binding affinity
and endogenous concentration because now
in theory we could
functionalize all available target
antibodies with tumor binding properties
and study the resultant immune function
so now we get what we're calling
covalently simplified ternary complexes
and and quaternary complexes to study
how this
modulates immune killing okay and i
already mentioned we use proximity
induced chemistry
to lock these reversible steps um
involved
in forming complex proteins uh protein
complexes
that activate the immune response
against the tumor
so we're going to dive in into a little
bit more detail now
and how we actually validate these
molecules and how key bli has been in
in executing this and we're going to
focus on a specific system
which again looks at going after the
specific subset of anti-dinitrophenal
antibodies
um that are naturally present in the
bloodstream at some
relatively undefined concentration and
so
take home message here is really our
overworking goal with these cleveland
recruiter molecules is to increase the
stability now
of these immunologically active protein
complexes on this
that we can now form on the surface of
tumors and to probe the resultant
effects
so just a little bit of detail into one
example
of the type of proximity chemistry and
system that you can use
what we're showing in this example
drives on this established acelamidazole
chemistry
this is a finely tuned kinetically
stable ester
where you can see again with our green
and red ligands one against the target
antibody one against the tumor but now
in this particular context they're
linked through this labial linkage
the idea was that this molecule would
bind to a ceremony antibody with a
certain affinity
akin to antibody engagers but now
you would have the reactive group in
close proximity to
nucleophilic residues proximal to the
binding site for dnp
on the antibody forming this
pseudo-intramolecular complex
followed by an enhanced rate of reaction
between this
amy and this ester okay and we're
currently exploring
several different chemistries and amino
acid residues
for these applications but the basic
idea is that
you can selectively label an antibody
that binds
with enhanced rates over other abundant
protein nucleophiles
present in the body so in this way we
thought we actually could use this tool
for individual potential
individual applications because we could
potentially in theory
selectively label and functionalize one
specific class of endogenous protein
and swap out the immune binding ligands
and tumor binding ligands to go after
different systems
so what we're going to talk about in
terms of the validation of some of these
molecules i'm just showing here their
chemical structures
again we have we have two basic domains
a domain that we're calling antibody
binding domain
in this case is a dnp hampton that binds
to anti-dnp antibodies
a target binding domain so for this we
chose to go after
an established tumor protein antigen
that's highly expressed on prostate
tumors psma which is well known in the
literature and link these together
through this acetyl metazoan
okay we could also swap out the target
binding terminus with a fluorescent dye
so that we could study fluorescent
labeling of the target antibody in
complex
matrices um we could swap it out with an
affinity handle like
like does the albion so that we could
study
binding and kinetics using the bli
platform and even potentially flow
cytometry
okay and also analogous compounds that
don't have this reactive asylum that is
all
so it's a highly tunable system we can
tune the chemistry the
what we're calling antibody labeling
domain as well as the target binding
domain
and the antibody or binding domain
okay and so now to really get into the
the meat and potatoes of the talk we
really want to feature
how octet has really has been so useful
in validating these complex
molecules and tools um so we wanted to
probe the selectivity of course of these
of these compounds for antibodies and
also
also be able to discern covalent
reaction from simply
binding the antibody the way that an
engager would this is important if we
want to accomplish selective covalent
recruitment
in vivo for example and so we thought of
you know when we first
first came about this we thought about
conventional methods to
prove covalent labeling we thought about
fluorescence polarization assays
where we thought about having you know
being able to measure three component
binding
in addition to the known artifacts and
aggregation events that can accompany fp
as well as how the fluorophore that you
put on can modulate the binding
interaction
flow cytometry um where we start to now
wrestle with non-equilibrium conditions
because of all the wash depths and the
shearing fluidics for example in the
regions they're also quite costly
and then we thought about mass
spectrometry which is a gold standard
for characterizing covalent labeling of
biomolecules but again for this you want
to really employ a pure
mono monodisperse protein species
whereas in the body these natural
antibodies would be polyclonal with
polydispersed structures
and so what we thought in the simplest
case was we could turn to octet and try
a bli assay and the way we envisioned
this was that we would immobilize on a
streptavidin probe
um our covalent immune recruiter
molecules so we should look at step one
where where we would work under
conditions well under the kd
of our molecule binding to the
antibodies so the dnp hapten is
is represented by the green sphere on
these covalent immune recruiters
and the red square in this particular
example is a death style biotin that
binds to streptavidin probes but it
could also be a bona fide
ligand against a tumor protein antigen
like psma we envisioned we'd get this
rapid we assumed we'd get a rapid
pre-equilibrium
um to a binding the non-covalent complex
followed by a slower irreversible step
uh class exaggeration kinetics where
again the hampton is expelled and we get
this covalent labeling of the antibody
and subsequent binding to the probe and
so we envisioned we would see
a fast increase in signal which
corresponds to the faster equilibrium
followed by a slower covalent reaction
leading to a slower phase and an
increased signal
again this is assuming a rapid
equilibrium and that our concentration
of antibody we're working with as well
under the kd
if the concentration of antibody is well
above the kd
then we wouldn't resolve these two
phases okay however we would expect to
see a larger
overall amplitude of binding of signal
so interestingly and as is often the
case we didn't observe what we had
anticipated
so shown here on the bottom is again the
same scheme to just remind you of the
type of assay that we set up here
with the bli okay in the red and blue
traces are us comparing a covalent
immune recruiter that can
label the antibody covalently with what
we're calling for simplicity
a non-covalent immune recruiter this is
really just a non-reactive version
you could think of it functionally
equivalent to and
the antibody engages i showed a few
slides ago
although we got we got very selective um
recruitment of the antibody you can see
in the the blue and red traces show
quite substantial association signal
when we add antibody
two probes that are pre-incubated
pre-loaded with the covalent immune
recruiter or the non-reactive equivalent
in the controls where we have
non-anti-dnp antibody
um or when we incubate these mixtures
with a high concentration of competitor
antibody binding ligands so just free
dnp we have close to baseline
association so we know that the
recruitment we're seeing is selective
antibody recruiting
however the covalent does not show any
advantage and in fact shows like there's
somewhat less signal than the
non-covalent version
um and so we were quite surprised by
this observation especially given we're
working at dilute antibody
concentrations well below the kd for
binding dnp or what is known in solution
also interestingly was that when we went
to to perform dissociation studies
so notion i was talking about how this
system is really well suited for looking
at chaos
we saw a chaos that almost did not occur
it almost looked like irreversible
binding in both cases
and so this is inconsistent with the
binding affinity of anti-dnp
for dmp which is which is reported
anywhere in the 20 to 80 nanomolar range
um
and so there was a few interesting
inconsistencies here the antibody
appeared to
to bind much more tightly than than was
expected
and also the covalent reaction did not
we could not discern covalent reaction
from non-covalent at this point we also
didn't know if the cirs were actually
even able
to label the antibodies this is one of
the very first studies that we did using
the bli
i like this because this is a really
nice example of basic fundamental
science and and validation and chemical
biology so i always like to include this
so you know we we generated a few
hypotheses we knew that the non-covalent
versions couldn't react
and so what we wanted so we hypothesized
that one reason for this really high
apparent binding affinity may be
a phenomenon known as binding avidity
um and so antibodies can bind to two
haptens um
if they're proc if they're close enough
together which you would expect
on a multi-valence surface such as a
probe on an octet but also on a cancer
cell
that expresses high concentrations of
your target protein
and so avidity without getting into too
much detail really manifests as a very
high apparent affinity
that you would not calculate in solution
in the absence of
this multivalent binding and so
we turn to some of the great literature
on this um by white sides and others
and came up with some strategies to
probe if indeed we were seeing binding
avidity here
and so if but if the antibody was
binding to the
ncir or the covalent immune recruiter on
the probe
we hypothesized that the addition
of competitor molecule during the
dissociation
phase would lead to a rapid chaos
which would not be the case if avidity
was not happening you can
feel free to look more into this
literature if you find this interesting
essentially the chaos is expected to be
independent of competitor if it's a
monovalent binding interaction
if it's a multivalent binding
interaction the chaos is
the apparent chaos is very perturbed by
the presence of competitor
because that interrupts with rebinding
which is which is what drives binding
ability and so i i
included a little scheme here for your
for your understanding
where we incorporate this competition
step during dissociation this blue dnp
glycine competitor molecules added
preventing rebinding
which we anticipated would lead to a
rapid chaos if
these antibodies were binding the probes
loaded
in covalent immune recruiter or
non-reactive analog
and lead to this rapid dissociation and
sure enough
if you look here when we perform the
dose dissociation of the presence of
competitor we now see a rapid
dissociation of antibody from the probe
which is highly consistent
with binding avidity also you'll notice
the dissociation amplitude is not nearly
as great
for probes that were that were coated
with proven immune recruiter as they
were with probes that were coded with
with non-reactive analogs and so you
would expect
that when the compound when the molecule
can now covalently recruit the antibody
it will no longer dissociate from the
probe in the presence of competitor
now some of you may be thinking about
but what about dissociation from the
target binding terminus
this is why we chose decile biotin to
load onto strep probes for these studies
because that affinity is so strong we
didn't have to worry about dissociation
on that end
in the context of these assays
and so now we we were excited because we
had what we thought was a way to
actually monitor
the ability of covalent immune
recruiters to not just bind a target
antigen on the surface which in this
case is simply streptavidin
but also measure covalent reaction with
time
and so on the next slide this is really
just another scheme showing
how we designed these assays we would
pre-incubate the probes with
a covalent immune recruiting molecule or
a non-reactive analog
we would then incubate them during the
association phase for fixed amounts of
time with anti-dnp antibody
again as we have we expected that we
would get a reaction selective or not
um which would correspond to haptic
ejection right if you remember that
acetyl metal the way it reacts
and then you would end up with antibody
that was either non-covalently found or
some fraction that was covalently
linked to the probe okay now remember
that the blue sphere is a very high
affinity does the
biotin strip tap in a binding
interaction then during dissociation we
flooded it with excess dnp glycine
competitor which
should dissociate all of the
non-covalently bound molecule even if
it's high avidity binding
okay and all that remains would be
covalently like the antibody
so by changing the incubation time we
could look at dissociation amplitude as
a readout of covalent
reaction and this enabled us to make
quite a bit of headway
in this in this validation okay now what
we're showing here
is some raw octa bli data
i'm showing the scheme on the top right
but just miniaturized just to remind you
of how the assay works
and what we can see now is through this
dissociation strategy we could discern
covalent reaction from non-covalent
binding
even though it was very high ability
which was also a very interesting
observation
by changing the incubation time which
which you can see here on the probe is
actually association time
we could measure fraction reaction
versus time
shown on the bottom which could also be
done in the presence of control antibody
that does not
bind anti-dnp because you'd expect if
this
is this is working as we hypothesize the
covalent reaction if it's selective
is dependent on binding to the antibody
okay
and so this allowed us to to to really
to perform
you know a number of critical controls
um
and evaluate different covalent immune
recruiters with that different
and subtle structural properties to try
and improve this proximity labeling
kinetics
we could estimate this
pseudo-intramolecular rate constant for
labeling
um of the antibody by the covalent
immune recruiter
okay now this being a complex
distribution of antibodies being
polyclonal which is what you would see
in the blood
we actually were not exactly sure what
the
amino acid residue was although this
chemistry is known to bias
amine labeling so we hypothesize it was
most likely a stable amide
or carbamate that was being formed to
the covalent immune recruiter
so not only do these assays rapidly
demonstrate
kinetics allow us to calculate the
kinetics of these covalent immune
recruiters
but also allow us to rapidly establish
selectivity and validate that these
molecules combined
to two different proteins simultaneously
which is not trivial and not to be taken
uh lightly and so if this actually could
work in vivo this would actually
essentially be a way of of programming
all of your naturally abundant anti-dmp
antibodies
with the ability to localize to the
tumor and what's really interesting
about this and potentially strategic
is the fact that these antibodies would
circulate for several weeks
giving you plenty of time to localize to
the tumor and mark them for immune cell
destruction
so after being able to validate the
kinetics in this manner
where the streptavidin probes are
preloaded with the covalent immune
recruiter and then antibody was
incubated
we wanted to go one step further and
look at bimolecular kinetics
so um some of you may be familiar with
this term k n active or ki
which is the hallmark measure of second
order
labeling kinetics in the proteomic world
using covalent chemistry
and so one reason why this is really
important to measure is because
in an in vivo scenario a lot of a lot of
the kinetics a lot of the
the majority of the time you probably
would be under this regime of second
order kinetics because
you're not under pseudo first order
conditions which you would only
achieve if you either added a very very
large axis of the covalent immune
recruiter to the bloodstream through
administration
or the affinity of the antibody that's
naturally abundant is
incredibly high okay in which case you
saturate that non-covalent complex
and then you have simply a first order
labeling reaction and so we wanted to
actually look
at at the kn act over ti kinetics and so
we developed another strategy
kinetic strategy again using the octet
but now instead of using these
streptavidin probes we use these pro-g
probes which capture igg antibody okay
and so this allowed us to monitor the
the covalent labeling reaction of
antibody in solution
and then we use a bonafide tumor protein
psma
as a readout of the covalent reaction
okay and in this way we could change the
concentration
of the covalent immune recruiter during
the reaction on the left
the loading phase okay and we could
actually monitor saturation kinetics
to both prove mechanism and also to to
determine this k
and x over k i calculation another thing
that we
really liked about this assay is enable
us to to probe
binding and covalent reaction in the
absence of avidity so we could very
clearly discern
binding from covalent reaction using
this type of assay format
so just to highlight this once again the
reaction that we're monitoring now is
occurring in solution
the probes are now pro-g probe so they
actually bind to the antibody
that is either non-covalently bound or
covalently linked
okay or not bound at all and in that way
we can
clearly measure monitor reaction
progress with time
okay
so on the next slide this is this is
really this scheme on the top is really
just a simplification of what i had
already showed where we monitored this
covalent immune reaction
um getting labeled antibodies that are
actually bound to the probe
and then we can actually determine the
proportion of labeled antibody
bound to the probe by adding recombinant
tumor protein antigen which in this case
is psma leading to an increase in signal
so this allowed us to to really make a
breakthrough in the kinetic
characterization of our compounds
you can see here that we can perform a
variety of controls the absence of the
antibody
using non dnp antibody
and really monitor the increase in
signal with time which is proportional
to covalent reaction
we can now clearly discern covalent
reaction from non-covalent binding
and by performing this reaction at
increasing concentrations of the
covalent immune recruiter
we could actually demonstrate saturation
kinetics
and calculate the actual k n act over ki
which we can see here are the constants
that
we were able to extract using the bli
on the next slide i just want to show a
little bit of data that
that is consistent with the validation
that was performed by the bli
itself so shown here is an sds
fluorescence sds page gel where we look
at labeling this antibody
directly in a hundred percent human
serum which has an abundance of other
proteins
on the left is a little cartoon of the
covalent reaction
um now we're looking at fluorescence and
so what we did was we swapped out the
psma binding molecule on our covalent
immune recruiter with a simple
fluorescein
so now we can see with nothing can hide
we can see every protein
that this molecule will label on the
left is your standard camachy blue and
on the right is fluorescence
in lanes one two and three we dope in
concentrations of antsy body
we now understand the kinetics of
labeling so we know what concentration
ranges to work in
okay and we simply look to see where the
fluorescence emerges and
consistent with the kinetics that we
determined using the bli
and the selectivity that the bli
indicated because in the bli kinetics
measurements we saw
very little to no reaction when we had
competitor dmp
or when we used antibodies that did not
bind the covalent immune recruiter
we would expect the antibody that we
doped in to appear on this upper band
okay are hovering just above the 150
kilodalton ladder
and then we added 200 nanomolar or one
micromolar anti-dnp to 100
human serum okay and you can see on the
right
this really strong fluorescent band on
lane two
okay and even fainter on lane one
um and these really just differ by our
addition of
five times more anti-dnp antibody okay
in lanes four five and six we add
competitor dmp ligand to out compete the
labeling reaction
to evaluate selectivity you can see it
all but disappears
and so we were really encouraged that
this molecule could selectively label
this antibody directly in this complex
matrix
you'll notice another band closer to the
50 which we attribute to the
very high abundance of hsa albumin
great at present here at greater than
500 micromolar concentrations
um 500 to 1000 times more than the
antibody we're doping in
and we envisioned that these the albumin
could be
labeled as an off-target reaction
because albumin is actually known to
bind to dnp with a reasonable affinity
and so we expect that these
covalent immune recruiter tools would
also label albumin
but with slower kinetics which is
exactly what we see here so the tools
performing
um exactly as we had designed it to and
so we this is quite gratifying
interestingly if we look at lane three
where we did not dope in any anti-dnp
antibody we just wanted to probe
the relative concentrations of the
anti-dnp
at least using our fluorescein system it
looks like the concentration of
endogenous anti-vnp
could be lower than what we anticipated
and below our limit of detection
but this is still an area that we're
actively pursuing um to be able to
quantify how much of these endogenous
antibodies
are actually present in our blood so
that we can understand
the ternary complex dependencies when we
use these therapies
um and so further validation um was to
actually employ mass spectrometer using
a model anti-dnp antibody that again is
only
one mono-dispersed protein
one sequence so we use this with a known
crystal structure
of a known anti-dnp binding site and
this predicted that our molecules would
label
lysine this particular specific lysine
over here 59
this is showing you a crystal structure
dock of our compound in the dnp binding
site
and upon performing mass spec proteomics
we were very gratified to observe that
only one
residue was covalently labeled by our
molecule it was the predicted lysine
59 and this is actually impressive
because
the antibody even on its own not even
thinking about
all the other antibodies and proteins in
our blood that have lysines
this alone has 44 unique lysines and the
molecule only labeled that one spot so
this really highlights the potential
power
of this approach um which is well known
in proteomics but in terms of covalent
immune recruiting
this is quite quite a novel finding and
something that we think will be very
useful
to probe these these complex protein
assembly processes and vevo
and modulate function and then i just
want to finish off with
with a little bit of of immune killing
immune functional data using these
molecules that were validated in the
octet
shown here is a classic flow cytometry
phagocytosis assay
these work by staining target cancer
cells shown here are hex cells that
express psma remember that's the tumor
protein antigen that we were going after
and uses in this particular case
monocytes so these are phagocytic immune
cells that will engulf a target cell
that is that is decorated with
antibodies with igg antibodies
and so you can see two colors coming
together in flow cytometry scatter plots
and you can
determine the proportion of dual color
events of
double color overlap okay and quantify
phagocytosis this way
and what we see here is that as we
increase the concentration of our
covalent immune recruiters
i'm in the presence of anti-dnp anybody
we get this classical bell-shaped
curve which shows that we are inducing
selective phagocytosis of
of cancer cells using these molecules
that can
bind to psma on the surface of the cell
and also covalently recruit and link to
anti-dnp antibody shown on the left are
controls
that typically include antibody that
does not bind
um to the dnp antibody binding domain on
the covalent immune recruiter
as well as psma competition molecule
like pnpa
okay which you'd expect to completely
disrupt phagocytosis
if the molecule is working through a
ternary complex engager
mode of action and on the right just
showing a little bit of the kind of
quantitations that we can perform
to make a long story short we basically
could
estimate the affinity of the ternary
complex for the immune receptor on the
monocyte responsible for phagocytosis
by performing this titration and fitting
this data
to ternary complex models okay it's
really also showing a schematic of how
the
the sierra molecule this is called three
that's the number that just donates the
fact that this can
this can target psma on prostate cancer
cells
and it binds to psma expressed on target
hex cells
um and the antibody then can engage in
this what's called the cb64 receptor on
phagocytes which then can lead to
receptor clustering and phagocytosis of
the targets which is what you're seeing
here
in this histogram
the reason for the bell-shaped curve if
anyone's curious is because as you
increase the concentration
of this covalently recruited antibody
you eventually reach
an auto inhibition scenario where you
have antibody that competes for binding
to the immune receptor now
um earlier in the presentation i had
mentioned autoinhibition
of the antibodies so you can see here
these are very relevant considerations
when you're dealing with
with therapeutics that binds to two
different proteins
okay and then lastly showing a different
type
of of functional assay this is actually
used to validate tumor immunotherapeutic
antibodies
that direct natural killer cell
cytotoxicity against cancer
we want to see if these cir molecules
could induce
cb16 receptor activation which is the
receptor on natural killer cells
that results in cytotoxic killing of the
tumor so this is
in in contrast to phagocytosis this is a
type of cancer cell killing
that employs cytotoxicity and as we
increase the concentration of antibody
of anti-dnp antibodies remember this has
no ability to bind to the target tumor
or activate the natural killer cell or
the cd16 receptor in the absence of the
covalent immune recruiter
and again we get a very interesting
dose-dependent increase
in cd16 receptor activation which leads
to abcc
when the molecule covalent immune
recruiter covalently recruits the
antibody
interestingly we don't see as much of an
effect if any
when the molecule cannot covalently
recruit and so this was something really
interesting
we anticipated that the that the real
impact would be
observed in vivo when the molecule could
be cleared
we did not envision in vitro to see such
a difference between covalent
recruitment
and non-covalent recruitment especially
at high concentrations of
antibody um so this actually is
something we're still investigating
um to look into the origins of of how
covalent immune recruiting is bestowing
such an advantage
in immune cell activation versus
traditional non-covalent approaches
um just very briefly if you look at the
black line that is our
our maximum condition where the molecule
the cir is incubated with antibody and
then added to the target cells in the
presence of these
immune receptors and then controls where
the same process is repeated
but with a non-reactive or you could
consider it an antibody recruiting
molecule control
okay which leads to much lower or
baseline levels
um we looked at the we look at covalent
immune recruitment at time
zero so before the reaction could occur
and see a certain substantial decrease
in adcc
okay so these controls together really
confirm the selectivity of the covalent
immune recruiter
as indicated by the bla data and also
points an interesting advantage
over non-covalent recruiting under
certain of sets of physical constraints
of concentrations and affinities and so
with that i'd like to just conclude
um that the bli you know for us really
could rapidly and efficiently validate
these novel
covalent recruiting molecules and
chemical tools
and we're able to discern covalent
reaction from from binding which is
no trivial task and really set the stage
for in vivo validation of these which is
where we're engaged now
currently we're working on a variety of
um
a variety of different related projects
in this platform
where we're developing these molecules
to selectively provenly link to two
different proteins as opposed to one
um and and covalently recruit the immune
cell directly
we're also engaged in developing new
proximity induced bioconjugation
reactions to incorporate into these
sierra molecules
and also look into more of the the kind
of physical biochemistry of these
processes and look at how these protein
complex concentrations and valencies
and stabilities govern the immune
activation
and we think that these findings will
find a lot of utility in guiding the
design of bona fide tumor
immunotherapeutics
so i would just like to thank you know
the students who are responsible
for all of this all of this you know
fantastic pioneering work
um these students are all incredibly new
the lab is only three years old
this kind of shows you with the right
instrumentation and the right students
um you can you can cover a lot of ground
and generate some
some some robust quality data so nick
sterny
ben lake edin kapkan rebecca turner and
cece yang
all from the chemical biology program at
mcmaster
and all have been with us for one to two
years um as undergrads
and now are joining as graduate students
in our third year so i'd really like to
thank mcmaster
our department of pathology and
molecular medicine and the mcmaster
immunology research center which
makes doing chemical biology research in
an immunology immunotherapeutic setting
possible
it would not be without this type of
infrastructure and
immunology support which is here thanks
so much to our granting
agencies that have taken a chance in
supporting our
early investigator work um
prostate cancer canada and circa and the
cancer research society and thank you so
much
to forte via to sorry to saratorius for
this fantastic opportunity
and for your support and all of you for
listening
thank you
thank you so much dr rulo and dr celine
for your informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar i see a lot of questions
coming in
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located to the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many of your questions
as we have time for today so i will turn
it back over
to dr rulo and dr saleem to answer some
of your questions
thanks sabrina thank dr rulo for a
fantastic presentation
so let's get in a few questions um
in a hypothetical application in vivo
what happens to arms that
performing its function how are they
cleared from the body
what could be the toxicity or side
effects
um of a non-reactive by antibody
recruiting molecule
um where we're defining those as as by
functional
inducers of proximity that do not
covalently link to their targets
so i'm i'm hoping that that's what the
what
what the questions specifically
pertaining to um they're rapidly cleared
most um
most rapidly through the urine um from
what we've seen these are still in their
pre-clinical stage
um but that tends to be the major
clearance pathway
and occurs within one to two hours um
what could be their toxicity side
effects um
you know in vivo with arms we really
have not seen a problem with toxicity
even with really high concentrations
i think a big reason for this is
is the cancer cells that you that you
that you go after
um typically have such a high
concentration of the tumor protein on
the surface relative to the healthy
tissue
that with the arms you're able to get a
multivalent display of antibody once it
does its job once it recruits the
antibody
and the immune system sees this
polyvalent display of antibodies and
goes after it and kills it
normal tissue even if a few arms bind it
you don't get enough antibody recruited
so it's this threshold immunological
response which is how immunology carries
out its specific tasks so well
okay we got another question so this
asks
whether is there a reason the antibody
engages
forms a covalent link
with the antibody before it binds to the
target cell
fantastic question fantastic and you
know we're also exploring what happens
when we
form it to the target itself first this
you know there's a lot of really cool
scientific questions to go after here
this is one of them
um this largely has to do with
how fast the reaction with the antibody
is designed to occur
um so when we design these anti these
these compounds
we try to optimize the reaction kinetics
for one protein over another a lot of
that's done by imposing geometric
restraints
and modulating linker properties and
reactive chemistries
and the distances between the reactive
group and the ligand binding group
and so you could um devise these so that
the reaction with the target cell
protein happens faster as well
so the answer your question is because
they've been designed so that the
proximity induced reaction occurs much
faster with the antibody than with psna
for example
and the fact that it would encounter
antibody
biologically in a biological system
before we encounter the targets almost
likely
okay okay um so
will these small molecules or can it
also act as
immune suppresses then
um could they they absolutely could they
can definitely be
used for aiming up for immunosuppressive
applications
this is something that we've thought
about but just don't have the bandwidth
to go after
um but absolutely you could use these to
sequester antibodies
to knock them out and flip things on its
head and use them for
autoimmune applications
okay absolutely
thank you so um another question uh it
how do you decide on the link between
the tbt and the abt its composition
or lent how how do you decide on it and
validate it
i mean it's a great it's a great
question it's a critically important
consideration um you know it this
depends on
a lot of logistical factors as well as
you know what you as an
investigator can actually pursue and in
what time frame so there's those
considerations as well
in theory you know a great place to
start is to look at what
you know giants in the field have used
and have worked well in similar
applications right and so
you know peg chains tend to work
decently well
there's a good trade-off in terms of
rigidity
versus flexibility as well as solubility
and as well as
price and ease of of synthetic
incorporation right
and then you would you know validate the
reaction kinetics and selectivity
but there's other potential linkers that
that that are worth exploring that have
branched alkane chains where you can
control
conformation of the linker uh
amniocepric acid has been very
successful
even hydrophobic chains may may bestow
um an interesting property um
sometimes we right now are introducing
heterocycles um
into these linkers to explore rigidity
triazoles
um where you can protonate them so yeah
it's a great question and there's an
infinite number of linkers
to choose from um i think to start
for proof of concept i think you want to
make sure
that it's soluble that you that it's
chemically stable so that you can
actually perform the covalent reaction
um and that it can keep the two
ligands um you know at least roughly
spaced apart with
with some sort of defined distance you
don't want it to be too floppy or too
rigid off the start while you're doing
your validation
because there's quite a trade-off with
these types of labeling reactions
you can you can you know you can gain
and you can
you can experience an entropic gain
by having it very pre-rigidified which
can really enhance your reaction rate
with the target protein nucleophile
but if that target protein nucleophile
is not geometrically positioned right
now you can't sample those other states
and so now you've kind of shot yourself
in the foot
so there's definitely a flexibility
rigidity trade-off with these types of
designs
okay i want to remind that we are
slightly over time but
i would go to the last two questions so
the rest the remaining questions we've
got a lot of questions to
uh to to professor rulo we will try and
we will follow up
with the questions that were unanswered
so with that uh
one question uh what would be the
advantage disadvantage of creating the
covalent complex
with antibody x vivo and then injecting
it rather than do the covalent reaction
in vivo
yeah no i mean it depends what your goal
is so that's a very good question i mean
if you
if you um wanted to develop a
a therapeutic there would be um
potential advantages to creating the
covalent complex vivo
um protein engineering is a you know is
very advanced there's
you wouldn't necessarily need affinity
labeling chemistry to execute that
you could engineer a residue and get
specific incorporation
the point of these compounds is to be
able to to kind of probe and modulate
proteins that are fixed by biology okay
in real time
that that's the reason for for wanting
to gain control over the covalent
complex in this manner
if that makes sense to you okay
okay yeah yeah sorry but go ahead
no i'm just going to say it really comes
down to what your application is
um you couldn't make an antibody drug
conjugating people
um in terms of therapeutics there in
terms of therapeutics there are
potential advantages
to introducing a small molecule like
vivo as well
or in vivo relative to larger biologics
there's a trade-off there as well so
that might be one reason why you you
wouldn't want to
to generate the covalent complex outside
as well from a therapeutic standpoint
tumor penetration and etc
final question um do you think this kind
of experiment can be done
using a surface plasma and resonant type
assay
i think that these types of experiments
could be
done with spr i think you have to be
careful of
clogging i'm using complex matrices um
for sure
[Music]
the throughput of the bli is very
advantageous being able to
do a line of these control experiments
while you're doing the actual assay
conditions simultaneously has been a big
advantage
um i think you could you could use spr i
don't know if
i'm not convinced that the throughput
would be as as good um
and i think you would run into i mean we
have like almost no logistical handling
problems doing these essays they're
they're i mean we had the the students
that i showed started doing this in
their third year of undergrad um rapidly
so this is something that you probably
wouldn't you wouldn't be able to do very
easily with spr
and especially when you have complex
matrices i mean these are
are larger biologics you're using
antibodies so right potentially doing
this with live cells
it's it would be tricky with spr
okay so with that um and due to
the time we want to respect everybody's
time as well i would like to thank
professor anthony ruler for the
fantastic presentation that was
really really informative and a cool way
to
look at covalent immune couplers using
label free
uh platform so and also i would like to
thank everyone
um who attended the webinar for your
time and um
you know it was good to discuss all
these questions
and we will follow up with whatever the
questions that you know we could not
answer today during this live session
thank you very much
thank you everyone
thank you so much dr rulo and dr celine
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their
interesting questions um questions that
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
those will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
um and we would like to once again thank
dr rulo and dr saleem for their time
today and their
important research we would also like to
thank labrutz and our sponsor sartorius
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
you can view the webinar on demand and
lab roots will
alert you via email when it's available
for
replay that is all for now until next
time
stay safe stay healthy goodbye everybody
thank you